OK, let's see.
Why don't we go next?
There's just so many people itching to get
on, I guess, is the way I would say it.
And we want to take a tour of different areas
for sure.
Let's go to I hope I'm saying this correctly.
Is it Sarrell from Texas or Sarrell?
Hi, David.
Can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
What is the origin of that name?
What a pleasure.
It is a combination of my first and second
name.
OK, very nice.
How are you today?
Good.
But I've been following for a while, and I
recently subscribed as well, so I thoroughly
enjoy the contents and I want to thank you
for that.
Thank you.
Basically, I just wanted to make a comment
on the importance of education and not only
institutionalized education, but what we're
seeing at home, if you like the the situation
right now in the US.
I live on the border, so I also get a taste
of Mexico and what's going on over there and
all the border issues.
But as an educator myself, I see this as a
reflection of many years of neglect in in
awareness and social awareness.
Right.
Our students right now have this this sense
of the detachment from the political reality.
And I feel like you've talked about it a lot
recently.
So the problem is, what do we do with all
these people that who voted for Trump and
who are champion champions of of of these
attitudes that cause us so much grief and
social destruction?
So in a way, I just want to make kind of like
a call of the about the importance of of making
this awareness from, hey, it's starting also
at home because these people are going to
vote in a few years and this is a circus.
So governments come and go later on.
You know, we're going to have to vote again.
And what are the choices that we tolerate,
all these all these attitudes if we normalize?
All right.
That was going to be my question to you, which
is by the time as an educator, by the time
they get to you, is it too late?
It really depends on starting at home.
That's a great question.
I teach high school and and college survey
courses, so this kind of at the right time
where youth, they're distracted by other things.
Right.
And developing a character.
But you see the behavior in the classroom.
And sometimes it is this is microscopic vision
of what we see in society.
The interactions, the rudeness, the things
that inherently come from home.
And these are values that have nothing to
do with religion, that have nothing to do
with anything but plain moral and being a
good person.
Well, that seems like a big hill to climb.
I, I think you're completely right.
But this is a big task.
Right, and that's why I also think that sometimes
governments do not invest enough in education
because it's a long term investment.
Yeah, your term is two, four or six years.
Why are you going to tie up a whole bunch
of money and things you'll never see the benefits
of as a politician?
Right.
Very sad.
So just does that.
And thank you so much for the work.
Keep it up.
And it's it's great talking to you.
Thank you so much.
Really a pleasure.
Let's take a quick break.
If you're holding on to talk to me.
Don't go anywhere because we're going right
back to the calls after this short break.